stupid HD why do I want HD so you can
all see my zip prick Kim your hair I
have a song for you oh boys and girls
it's that time of year again it's time
to show up all our generosity to our
friends we've been waiting for 364 days
in which we've been real good and done
all of our chores but I think that it's
important that we think of those out
there to whom we do not get present even
know we really care cuz there's just one
man who gets nothing each year and it's
certainly not because you've been bad
how he longs to hear Santa's reindeer
but it never hasn't yeah that makes him
sad he never hasn't yeah that makes him
sad because everyone think of Jesus on
the eve of Christmas but nobody thought
that but him on their list so Jesus gets
nothing for Christmas yet Jesus gets
nothing or Kris
when he was a boy back in Galilee he
didn't get presents cuz Christmas stick
things just you see and now that he's
grown nobody could have guessed that he
really what's the 24-piece metric drill
bit set yet Jesus wasn't carpenter you
know that that is true and he's tired of
using two thousand year old tools just
because if a man gets nothing each year
even though he hasn't been bad how he
longs to here's Santa's reindeer but he
never hasn't yeah that makes him sad man
he never has in Yana vixen sad you know
everyone thinks of Jesus on the eve of
Christmas but nobody thought to put him
on their list so Jesus gets nothing for
Christmas yet Jesus gets nothing for
Christmas all he wants is world peace
but he also really like look that new
old baby please sit yeah he wants to end
violence and war buddy kind of the
entire concept autumn or he gives no
milk and cookies like that Pat Santa
Claus does he's the reason for the
season buddies always said because he is
the man who gets nothing each year even
though he has it been bad how he longs
to hear Santa's reindeer but he never
hasn't yeah attics inside
he never hasn't yeah that makes him sad
because everyone thinks of Jesus on the
eve of Christmas but no one ever thinks
to put him on their list so Jesus gets
nothing for Christmas
yeah Jesus gets nothing for Christmas
oh Jesus just doesn't know what to do he
doesn't wanna seem like an ungrateful
youth then the worst part is it's his
birthday too
and Jesus get something for
I hope no one takes that too seriously
outtakes wow that's my hand my desk when
she was up boy back in Galilee he never
got Francis cuz he didn't exist Jesus
didn't exist interesting he doesn't want
to seem like an ungrateful youth then
the worst part is my cell phone just
rang he was a boy back in Galilee
[Music]
what the Frick okay I would have been
mad at that person but it was Bill
Martin and he was sending me a link to a
really awesome video and this video
happens to be over now so you can click
on that video annotation link here I
think it goes without saying that the
project for awesome was pretty freaking
awesome this year we will be talking a
little bit more about it soon but I just
wanted to get this video up because it's
Christmas time and I want to sing
Christmas song God bill stop it's the
messaging me was actually John okay I
gotta go bye